the bomb
the bomb
do you realize what you've said I should
do it's pounded in my brain awful enough
was sleep and awaken in the drowsy
fantasy moment of every lonely dog
what's your answer
[Music]
what's your answer
if I tell my mom and she tells your mom
if
[Music]
Oh such a wonderful sip sonam its topo
Chico which is very refreshing in their
bubbly but there's a part of me that
doesn't trust anything that comes from
Mexico hey you said it I didn't
not people what I learned commodity he
said things people yes you just boomed
in my fall
is that your everyone you subscribe if
you're listening in half-asian builders
blew your ears out we're sorry but he's
a lawyer so there's no way you're gonna
catch him on that swing which one half
agent Larry bill Richman is here 8 year
old a is here black audio Wade is here
please do subscribe on the iTunes
whatever does the Spotify there's
Crowder bits and do consider joining my
club because we do like a full hour
after this every day the morning mug
club a full hour of additional show but
first let me ask you a question how long
do you think Chaz sorry chop it's a
little it's confusing because they're
walking human vaginas occupational
protest occupy protest what he's heard
about you can't get me I'm on base right
it was like those when Cubans would come
and had the touchdown rule I used to
write watch real TV yeah there's a Cuban
who came over you know like I think I
got a lounge chair floated over and then
she caught it and he think like he can
deke him out like he stiff arms him and
touches it the barrier and the cops are
just like tank right over look this
isn't tienamin square bill come on that
was the reference he can make it but now
your race out
I've always hidden correction no just
now by the way what do you think this
ends with the statues being torn down
we'll talk about that quite a bit where
do you line up on the Confederate
statues that were being taken down do
you think that people do didn't defend
those statues sort of paved the way for
George Washington and Jefferson coming
down now which was predicted but mocked
let us know and of course live chat is
available exclusively at blaze we'll be
reading some of your chat later but
first we actually have another update a
preview for tonight's newest installment
reformatted cops tonight
[Music]
state unions award no it seems like you
to change a theme song means the
criminals yeah this is a bad song now
yeah by the way well also a little bit
later we'll be showing this review who
our mud club members how to defend
yourself against a macy's attack because
this happened that's the n-word in the
clearance section people trying to get
deals and that was a Macy's rack
justified and yet black those men
activists and what's the name tarika and
the sheet reeked machine that is in this
race warrior he was out there they
claimed it the man used the n-word and
that justified the attack which of
course it wouldn't and he never said it
turns out he's a store employee in the
electoral security frigate was
completely unprovoked we'll talk more
about that so that you don't have to get
your ass kicked and the defense
shouldn't just be naughty word we won't
talk about Chazz yes I really did I mean
do we start making statues now or don't
know it's gonna last that much next week
so they had actually a they had a second
shooting last night realist and that's
been to write two in a row two shootings
though they haven't confirmed the second
shooting but let's just mainly focus on
the first shooting cuz that's we had a
footage by the way how much do you have
any bodies do you think are buried there
seven seven to eleven to agree yeah I
mean there's nothing you could do they
could just literally put that in the
middle of jazz they could pull a Walter
White and just do it with a bucket of
acid just put it inside the cardboard
and
yeah well they put a tent over it and be
like here's what you bring the person
you killed there obviously that of
natural sir this one has a knife in his
back well natural causes so there was a
shooting though Saturday at 2:30 a.m.
and this is this is important because
will touching us a little bit more and
we have a lot of info on Chaz coming up
a Steinbeck and of course the cops and
the ambulance by the way the medics
because they called in the medics when
two people shot one was killed and one
was really injured they called him the
medics and then accused the medics of
being racist because the medics couldn't
get through I think we have a video from
R as Simone tweeted this out is that
that's not that so R as here's the tweet
from rad Simone
razzmatazz roll that's what we're doing
you guys could be saving this man's life
right now
but instead of doing that you're gonna
wait here you guys are that afraid
there's no way there's no way this is in
your hearts if he dies it's on you guys
you could have saved this life you could
you guys Kenneth this is bullsh and you
know it sir is what if that was your son
up there right now would you want this
to happen to your son I want oh man this
is amazing
this is what's happening in America
right now there are rescue say this is
life John now they're waiting to say to
James fine he's dying bleed on hairlines
you're trying to bust through that crowd
right now but you're not because it's a
black light because it's a black light
well before we move on cuz you just
mentioned that what's in the bar rescue
guys John
not John Tesh I know but what is it to
someone know that name can find it bar
rescue music member you load in your
book come in here Phil you don't even
have you don't even have a draft John
John John
rescue this is going down unless I come
in and do so well so here's the thing
they were saying because it's a black
life first off the ambulance the medics
couldn't know that it's a black life
right but there's also a reason by the
way that you don't block cops from
getting in because the cops have to
clear the way legally of course for the
medics the ambulance and this is what
was going on at the barricades a chasm a
chief a chief or whoever is on down
there the victim is left the police of
the police have entered the zone the
police the police have entered his own
the weapons are out you've got people
here for they formed a human chain to
try to stop traffic through through this
a human war that the purpose of this
human war that we see right here is to
build a barrier in between what the word
Wow well here's the thing if you want
the medic to get through your human wall
is a human speed bump so take your pick
yeah exactly
we built the human wall I've got to save
the bar people don't understand like
this isn't it happened - I believe in
Minneapolis we talked about it there was
a woman any child in a building on fire
and they could see the fire department a
few blocks away the cops were clearing
away for the fire department and then
the clot that the cop cars were
completely blocked yeah so this is one
of those things where you can say people
are violent extremists but let me ask
you this as a genuine this is where we
could see some kind of a fight back and
some kind of a civil war from people who
aren't militiamen if you're a father and
you know and this actually happened that
your mom that your wife the mother of
your children your child in a house that
is burning down and you can see the fire
department and you can't get them out of
the house and you see people blocking
the cops so the fire department can't
get through is that man a madman is he a
lone mad gunman if he starts taking
people out to try and save his wife and
child I'm not saying that I advocate
that but I'm saying you are pushing
people to extremes at this point where
they will take extreme measures this
does not end well
and that is the rule medics paramedics
ambulances particularly in areas where
there's violence it has to be cleared by
the police yeah otherwise you have any
idea how easy I've been shot and then
they come in like morphine thanks [ __ ]
too much exactly and by the way every
time that vehicles with flashing lights
approach these peaceful protests they
tend not to do well they tend to get set
on fire they tend to get burned turned
over windows get busted out like we've
seen video of this from everywhere why
why would you want these guys to put
their lives at risk when every time they
do you hate them and you try to do stuff
to them maybe kill them hurt them
destroy their property whatever right
that's why I advocate that we should put
in a charged electric current on all
vehicles with flashlights like Simon
flies
[Laughter]
you know what the guys said at the very
end he goes if it was your kid in there
you would bust through that barrier
basically he just said take your vehicle
and run over those people that are
blocking the road that we thought was a
good idea it's never okay for police
it's never okay for police to run over
protesters in the case that one area in
New York they actually yeah I thought it
was brilliant they used the what he
calls like metal barriers that are like
a metal barrier the protesters weren't
so he got specifically behind the metal
barrier windows and the metal barrier
went flying so they all went perfectly
perpendicular to the ground backward
what if the medics are trying to come in
behind them to save lives
what if that person by the way we don't
know what if the medics had got to
gotten to him sooner and he didn't have
to die that's you blocking the cops
plane for people who don't know though
that's there's clear precedent there
that's what they have to do the issue
becomes for example if you were to say
well oh I'm blocked on the highway and
I'm not gonna move out of the way of
emergency vehicles where everyone is
taught from a young age you need to
clear the way from your ankles and it
really does it pushes people to the edge
to say if you especially when you can
see that it right okay if the fire
trucks not there it's too far away the
ambulance isn't even there yet whatever
they're dealing with protesters in other
parts of the city okay but to be able to
see it and then even if you just have
the dad run down there and start pushing
people out of the way in the example
that you gave in any of those examples
you're asking for a time in which you're
having to put one life against the other
and all they're doing is protecting
their ya little garden yeah and you know
what this is what if they misconstrue
when I say you forfeit your right to
live there's a difference being that and
you deserve to die
yeah in other words you punch someone in
the face on a sidewalk where they can
bounce their head off the concrete you
hold a knife to someone where it's their
life or yours you put them in a
situation where there's a reasonable
assumption that they could be killed you
forfeit your right to live in that that
person is justified in taking measures
to protect their own life and you could
be the victim of an accident you could
just as easily kill him not bounces it
off the concrete and he could just as
easily bounce your head off the concrete
you could just as easily reach in and
shoot that medic which happens or they
could just as easily accidentally
run you over Kratz with the chatter no
Jesus a single yo is 8 going out it's an
all black no we're all good we're just
putting seeing inlet I'm sorry they have
breakfast burritos over there what are
you doing with this is an they were
independent I thought they wanted to
have their freedom and their
independence and that they were able to
set up they said they had medics in this
story when you read it they're like our
medics were on scene and doing a
fantastic job other than not knowing
what the hell they were doing and being
high out of their minds at the time they
were a bunch of rolling papers let's see
what's going into a damaging future if
Trump were reelected the military
intelligence government government for
50 years how are you somebody send
Bolton over to fight a war let's just
see how he does by the way we need the
walk-in buys a bar that's that's the
show that's you're doing right now what
Christopher Walken buy suppose Walken
that voice has a little bit of walking
in it no it does it does there's in
context it's you drugs no you come back
from Chaz no I'm not an international
reporter Stephen yeah they will be
stunned to find out you are not amongst
them huh I'm removing your knee
from the pulitzer running so they've
been some statues torn down removed
across the united states now obviously
this started with a lot of confederate
statues monuments and i will suspect
that's like listen conservatives who are
choosing that as the hill to die on in
the sense that this is absolutely
something we want to identify with the
confederates were people who tried to
basically undercut the united states
let's be clear they lost they didn't
want the america that you have but i
don't think that you should be taking
down all of these statues and monuments
I think if you municipality wants to
vote and say hey we want to change that
statue go to the legal process Who am I
to stop that district I'm doing that but
there needs to be a vote and it needs to
come from the public and I think you
probably get half-and-half depending
where you are you cannot erase all
history because it's somewhat offensive
and I understand many people say well
hon the Confederacy fought for slavery
and I do I understand it slavery bad
want to be really clear but we have
often asked and so did Donald Trump well
where does it end if anyone is being
judged by today's standards and they're
imperfect you could end up taking down
they want to take down Lincoln we could
go Washington of course that was roundly
mocked as the logical fallacy of
slippery slope argument by many in the
media including John Oliver president's
concern seems to be that tearing down
statues leads to a slippery slope this
week it's robert e lee i noticed that
stonewall jackson's coming down i wonder
is it George Washington next week and is
it Thomas Jefferson the week after
you know you oh you really do have to
ask yourself where does it stop okay
well I'll tell you where it stops
somewhere anytime someone asks where
does it stop the answer is always in
somewhere you might let your kid have
Twizzlers but not inject black tar
heroin you don't just go after the
Twizzlers where does it stop
right you receipt like you know like all
those funny videos like look at my kid
which is really just like hey my kid
isn't he's such an idiot right I do this
you an adult that's what's really cute
it's like what a kid does that we find
cute if it were an adult yeah a special
school see if we could work this out of
them but the things this is what John
Oliver does and this is what people on
the Left often do but John Oliver is the
worst and that's what we try and create
it or at least propose constructive
solutions like I just mentioned a
municipality
do that John Oliver never does he goes
well it stops somewhere and he never
gives you that somewhere right exactly
and that's so in other words if you're
going to stop a slippery slope argument
in by the way just because it's a common
argument doesn't mean it's a logical
fallacy you know I talked about that
with making okay if gender is now
cultural and sex is biological but then
you can be born into the wrong sex and
you include sort of well I'm attracted
to men they're from same sex but sex is
biological and on a second this is all
going to deconstruct and now we see that
the Supreme Court ruled that success is
how you feel yeah not just gender but
biological sex so now we're at the point
where gender and sex are one in the same
right so there's a valid argument
sometimes with the slippery slope
the counter-argument has to be hey this
is where it stops but you have to draw
your line and what he's doing is just
applying their logic to a different
situation right so if you're taking down
robert e lee because he was a southerner
who owned slaves then you have to take
down Jefferson because he was a
southerner who owned slaves so take the
same logic apply it to a different
person right that's essentially the
argument and yeah and they might have
argued well he wasn't fighting for
slavery but here's the thing it doesn't
matter because now they want to take
down Abraham Lincoln but here I think we
actually have yeah we have a clip of
what Christopher Columbus Thomas
Jefferson George was so he here it is
John Oliver it's been the target of
vandals for years and today it's gone
mayor Duggan ordering the Statue of
Christopher Columbus be removed from its
perch at Jefferson and Randolph and put
in a storage we've got brand-new video
here but coming down today a Fox 12
viewer sent us this video of the statue
of the nation's 3rd president as it was
pulled down while Thomas Jefferson wrote
all men are created equal he also owned
as many as six hundred slaves during his
lifetime and fathered slave children I
used to be in Northeast Portland
this was near Northeast at 57th and
Sandy Boulevard about 11:00 last night
police tell us that statue was also a
banned alized and the group ran off once
officers got to the scene okay so not
only is that a gross misrepresentation
of Jefferson and Washington and slavery
where they reviled it I'll get to a
couple quotes in a second but again
let's show you that that doesn't even
act as at the end point for them right
yet slave you had people who fought for
the Confederacy people who fought for
slavery right that's what we're gonna
take this down that's it people
I don't think that's it you want to
recall history then we were mocked we
said was it going to be George
Washington is it going to be Jefferson
who by the way on many of them procured
slaves from African slave traders if you
read a lot of the founding fathers
because that's where the slave trade
started in the Middle East we'll get to
that in a second
people said no no because that's a
different well now they want to get rid
of that but then it continues to place
that people don't even make sense
they actually they're going to remove
the teddy roosevelt statue from the
Museum of Natural History
cuz reasons that wasn't a slave owner
I don't think so they said it actually
portrayed the people next to him the
Native American and a black person right
serving well huh they also black eyes
matter now they're they vandalize the
statue of John great John Greenleaf
Whittier a quick abolitionist Teddy
Roosevelt Street stuff and will go back
to Washington Roosevelt there are some
speeches here that you can actually read
but um the attitude of the north toward
the Negro is far from what it should be
and there is need that the north also
should act in good faith upon the
principle of giving to each man what is
justly due him of treating him on his
worth as a man granting him no special
favors but denying him no proper
opportunity for labor and the reward of
labor and this comes from I believe
National Geographic in his argument for
racial equality Roosevelt used the
rising tide raises all ships metaphor
stating that if morality and thrift
among the colored men can be raised then
those same virtues among whites already
assumed at that point to be more
advanced not meaning as humans but
advanced economically would rise to an
even higher degree at the same time he
warned at the debasement of blacks will
end will in the end carry with it the
debasement of whites this was something
Roosevelt spoke out against racism and
talked about how everyone needed to be
provided equal opportunity equal rights
and he could even argue that there he
uses the word Negroes therefore it was
racist right you you can definitely you
have to stop one of my problems with
this is that most of the time people
just don't know what the hell they're
doing even if it's somebody who happened
to own slaves
I guarantee most of the people there had
no clue somebody just pointed and said
that that's a white guy who was bad he's
part of the patriarchy probably owned
slaves whatever in the private life and
pull it down right but well and that's
an oxymoron a bronze white man let's not
rods are just trying to get into the
client
I do I do look as a person of color I
would like to stop let's draw the line
right all your arms drawing because you
make the stretch after we remove all
British comedians who are kind of you're
colonizing yes our country yes with
their racism I believe that's a good
point what can we can we Viktor Hannah
Gatsby all of it my mom is from Hong
Kong all right she suffered through
colonialism under the British under the
John Oliver's of her time and here he is
telling me telling my family what to do
I think
well the somewhere is on the other side
of him being removed no I don't know we
don't what's funny about that is that
we're also not once or we ever saying
cancel him right right put his own
argument logically leads to him being
cancelled right
yeah I'm just watching the politician
the new season I can't really watch it
because Bette Midler is just you know
just like just let her go with it and
that Midler is doing her hocus-pocus
Ecch
oh oh this is so comical from the lefty
environmentalism and the the LGBTQ AIP
you think that maybe it's written by
someone's a libertarian with balance and
then you realize that can't be the case
when they actually are canceling in this
series a man running for office because
it's a six year old he dressed as
Geronimo do you think oh this must be a
joke it's good he actually gives a
speech like I should have known better
and I didn't and I apologize this is an
industry that can't people because
they've actually gone out and said hey
you know what we should all come
together as one nation so you realize
there can be no balance in this industry
and this is what's happening right now
because people believe this about
Washington Jefferson I want to get some
quotes here from Washington Jefferson
here reviled slavery but here's
something else we're talking about being
consistent and this isn't a what about
ISM let me explain to you why guess who
else that's late mmm-hmm notable person
in history who I think I personal
opinion was a real jackass also child
right hmm
Rachael Ray Rachel Maddow Muhammad was a
slave owner and it was Hill Hall saying
yeah but that was a but that was a
different time
well same to what Jefferson in
Washington but Washington famous ladies
of hundreds upon his death which was
really as soon as he could and also his
wife wear the pants and she was kind of
pro-slavery so that kind of complicates
matters
Muhammad did have slaves and here's a
question okay
they both had slaves a different point
in time is there slavery in the United
States today no is there slavery in the
Middle East is there slavery in Saudi
Arabia clock boy hides his Phillips
alarm clock in a Samsonite
there's indentured servitude that there
is still slavery yeah all across the
Middle East and Asia and Africa not in
the United States so what do we do with
any why you can't have physical
portrayals of Muhammad no but even this
long tear down as long as I guess yes I
guess Mecca
cancel and we think about Mecca when you
think what it's about what it symbolizes
this is a guy who could have had the
opportunity to speak out or free of
slaves all of them upon his death didn't
do it like Washington that's a monument
to the slave trade that still continues
yeah you got to go to the Dome of the
rock I guess cuz that's where he you
know send a go there and tear it down
geez if you really are oh my god I don't
know someone to put up a statue of
Muhammad on their own private property
just to see what happens
kind of like the Lenin scaled as a
primary straight after that statement
that's true there's a quick quote if we
can I don't know if you've got the the
Orwell quote because it was just an
interesting thing it talks about statues
it talks about history and talks about
books it was from the book 1984 they'll
bring it up in just a second but it was
it was put out there right so it's like
every record has been destroyed and for
falsified every book is rewritten every
picture and repainted every statue in
street building has been renamed every
date has been altered in the process is
continuing day by day minute by minute
history has stopped nothing exists
except the endless present in which the
party is always right that's not the
world that I want to live in and I
understand like you said if there are
things that you want to personally I
understand that but his point is
very valid mhm right his I don't care
where he came from no no he ate a lot of
great points but he didn't connect right
as well I'm not I'm not endorsing him
you know I'm endorsing that specific
statement that says hey you can't just
rewrite stuff if you don't like it use
it as a teaching moment did a great
thing George Washington did something
that no person in history has ever done
have complete power and then give it up
break he gave it back to the people he
also did some bad stuff so let's talk
about that too what used to be those who
forget history are doomed to repeat it
now it's those who do not tear down and
erase all history from the books that
might be slightly offensive by today's
standards are canceled and be typically
couldn't fuchsias say yeah so here's a
quote from here's some quotes from
Washington Jefferson because Washington
specifically freed his slaves upon his
death and when people say Oh Jefferson
had slave children we we can get into
that and we'll get into that with David
Martin later on
concerning the path Washington desire to
see the states choose he emphatically
declared this is from Washington I can
only say that there's not a man living
who wishes more sincerely than I do to
see a plan adopted for the abolition of
slavery but there's only one proper
ineffectual mode by which it can be
accomplished and that is by legislative
authority and this as far as my suffered
vote and support will go shall never be
wanting and then Jeffers Jefferson's
ever since Jefferson Jefferson's efforts
to end slavery were written about before
the American Revolution he wrote in 1769
I became a member of the legislature by
the choice of the county in which I live
in Virginia and so continued until it
was closed by the revolution I made one
effort in that body for the permission
of the emancipation of slaves which was
rejected and indeed during the regal
crown government nothing like this could
expect success so these are you know
what it would be like it would be like
right now looking back at let's say
there was some actual gross violation
actually occurring at the hands of the
government and luckily I'm not are
protesting it but not getting anything
done and then a hundred years from now
then being cancelled because well you
didn't change it but you can see
Washington and Jefferson actively right
tried to use their power in positions in
government to change it and then someone
like Washington through the legal
process yet available freed his slaves
immediately upon his death this is
opposed to Muhammad who kept them till
the day he died and as symbolized by
Mecca
alright so let me know what what do you
want to say Jefferson also said all men
are created equal it's it's one of the
the greatest statements in history that
we have from a leader and you're tearing
him down and even after he did that you
know after he went down that path look
Gerald it doesn't make any sense what
you're saying the entirety of the
movement is based on honoring equality
in a constitution that was written by
white men equality is racist yes that's
a conclusion that's a very good tear it
all down I think it's a good note tenon
let me know if you agree with Gerald or
with Bill Germany slavery and mekka
channey but for now we're going to go to
Mudd Club exclusive another whole hour
do join it lateral credit.com slash Mudd
Club but YouTube piss off